having been around
jerry and having been around a lot of
different guys then does that mean
is the best when when you're when you're
putting a team together
what is your number one is your number
one putting a coach like pop together
that's going to keep the players for a
while
or is the number one getting a good gm
is the number one getting the superstar
like giannis
what is the number one to keep not
necessarily the golden handcuffs but to
be able to get
a team that's willing to be in a market
like san antonio
which you know it's not necessarily the
craziest sit outside of the three rivers
stadium and the alamo you got nothing
really going on over there
i'm starting from day one i want the
best player because you need the best
player
to establish any kind of competitiveness
and greatness but if i want to
start from scratch with this notion of
what's most
important most important is committed
ownership
so you need deep pocketed passionate
ownership that's in it for the right
reason because over time that's what
sustains things and wins
and you want a good head on that guy's
shoulders or gal
whoever that owner is somebody that will
then go
hire good management so in your san
antonio spurs example
you had solid ownership that just got
popovich and rc buford as this
incredible tandem to lead basketball
operations and to maintain
this incredible level of success over
the years in spite of being in a small
market
it was just you know 20 years of
exceptional
work there but there's no
question it's a talent game so in that
scenario
if you're if you're giving me for one
year the best owner the best coach or
the best player i'll take the best
player
who's the second second in that show
go with that do your draft best owner
best gm best player best coach
first is best player what second if it's
for one year it's the best coach because
he's going to have the most influence on
performance
okay give me if you want to build a
legacy like if you want to build a
10-year run so if you're first as player
what's your second well if it's a
10-year run i
i it's still best owner you got to have
the best owner to give you the chance to
make all those maneuvers and you know
and to do all that then you got to have
great management
you know just building got it okay got
it
so you're going you're going owner gm
coach player
honor gm player coach owner okay
got it interesting owner gm
player coach and why is coach last for
you
because the coach is only as good as his
players
i mean you know the great coaches pick
the great talent to go coach
that's how it works um
yes there's this theory that you get an
amazing coach and he's gonna max out
whatever talent he has but that's only
within a
a small band of a small percentage if
you put
greg popovich with the worst talent in
the league
he may win them five more games
so they go from 15 wins to 20 or 22
but he can't take a 15 win talent tip
may get it to
500. i wonder if he sees this if he'll
be offended by that if you'll say come
on
you know i'd take him into the playoffs
even if he gave me a bunch of scrubs
i'm sure he would agree with you on that
but so if that's the case who would you
put right now as the best coaches in the
nba
coaches in the nba well pop is still you
know
over time as good as it gets just a
master
what i look for in a coach is a master
relationship
expert and a tactician you know and a
competitor and everything that goes with
that and greg popovich is just truly
amazing
um eric spoelstra has quietly
done just a remarkable job over the
years down in miami
uh you know a great guy a very
incredibly heart a credible hard worker
managed that
unusual transition to come in
and succeed pat riley who's one of the
biggest personalities and
most respected just nba studs you know
just a
he's pat's revered by so many folks for
what he's done in so many different
places and just kind of who he is
um and uh spoelstra has just done a
remarkable job of uh
navigating through all that so you put
full stress second
behind uh interesting well i don't know
on my list in front of me there are
plenty of others he just jumped into my
head
yeah i mean listen it's respect because
even if you think about it who the hell
thought last year miami was going to go
to the finals and let alone win a couple
you know nobody thought they were going
to go that far and that's a lot of
credit for spoelstra so if you like this
sort of shortcut from an interview i did
click over here to watch the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel take care
everybody bye